it does occur to me that you have this
uh absolutely fantastic uh british
accent
and occasionally and i know you've you
have lived in the united states now
for 20 years is that right 20 years
and i have spoken to many actors who've
uh transitioned to the united states and
they start to lose their accent you have
not
do you feel that you have assimilated
to being an american i do think that i
have learned
um i've learned a lot of things
as an american i've learned how to fill
a glass of wine
all the way to the top that kind of
thing
that is that is what we do we think
nothing of going right up to the rim
right to the brim because uncle hank uh
my american uncle hank tells me he says
um
filling it halfway causes a wasted
journey so
uh that was very very smart but i will
tell you the one thing that i haven't
been able to
uh figure out is how to wear a baseball
cap i just it just doesn't
work on me the whole the whole game's up
if i try to wear one
i kind of look like um well i kind of
look like ron howard's
elderly brother or something
oh there you go oh yes definite
you you look like ron howard's brother
who's an accountant yes
that's right it's just it's just it's
just not a lot that is
ever going to work on me so yeah and and
that is something that seems to be
kind of mandatory in the united states
is that they insist that you wear a
baseball cap or everyone has to wear a
baseball cap
i don't wear a baseball cap because you
have i'm gonna
compliment you now you have a very
chiseled lean face
um i have the large bloated pumpkin
the irish are cursed with and when i put
a baseball cap on it only makes my face
look
fatter it accentuates the fatness of my
face
and then i my self-loathing kicks in so
i i don't like it
um i i think that you and i should just
like knuckle down and start wearing
baseball caps and you know what i
i took it off because i was ashamed of
uh
that's a shame but i'm gonna wear it
okay well i
i i think it looks terrible okay
well no because i'm massively shallow so
you said that
and my my vanity kicked in
so i you know yeah well i think you
you're obviously well dressed i like
your jacket is that a motorcycle jacket
well is it a motorcycle jacket i mean
it's like a motorcycle jacket if
dior did a motorcycle
i was wearing a motorcycle jacket and i
went in
it was in a bar in brooklyn i went into
a bar
and i sat down to have a drink and this
guy was like he was very drunk and he
looked at me with a nice
nice motorcycle jacket i went oh thank
you so much and he said
you have a motorcycle and i went uh
no he went to why you got a motorcycle
jack like this and i went
you're wearing a baseball hat do you do
you play
baseball you bastard
and that does that story end with you
being beaten very badly
yes it ends it ends with yes it ends
with me being beaten in the kidney
welcome to america yeah
you